[Música]
el presidente estadounidense Joe biden
reiteró su llamado acabar con la
violencia Armada luego del tiroteo en la
universidad Estatal de Michigan que dejó
tres personas muertas y que se da en el
contexto del quinto aniversario del
tiroteo de la escuela de parkland uno de
los peores del país
que también en Estados Unidos las
autoridades detuvieron a cuatro personas
por su presunta participación en el
asesinato del presidente de Haití veniel
Moisés en 2021 Total ya son 11 detenidos
en suelo estadounidense por el
magnicidio
aumenta a 25 el número de muertos por
los incendios en Chile los peores
registrados en su historia las
autoridades continúan combatiendo las
llamas que se estima han consumido al
menos
425.000 hectáreas de bosque un equipo de
France 24 visitó las zonas afectadas
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Estados Unidos el presidente Joe biden
reiteró el martes su llamado al congreso
para que tome medidas contra lo que
calificó de epidemia de violencia Armada
en el país sus declaraciones se
produjeron Un día después de un nuevo
tiroteo en un campus universitario de
Michigan que causó la muerte de tres
personas a mal venosman nos cuenta más
una pesadilla que sucede con demasiada
frecuencia así se refirió el presidente
de Estados Unidos Joe biden al último
tiroteo ocurrido en Michigan tres
personas perdieron la vida y cinco
resultaron gravemente heridas el
mandatario imploró una vez más a la
opinión pública y a los congresistas
para que actúen en materia de control de
armas
tenemos que hacer algo para detener la
violencia Armada que destroza nuestras
comunidades que las destroza hemos dado
un gran paso hacia la aprobación de la
legislación bipartidista sobre armas la
importante de los últimos 30 años pero
queda mucho trabajo por hacer y me
comprometo a conseguirlo con todos
ustedes el atacante del Campus de
Michigan abrió fuego el lunes 13 de
febrero sobre las 20:30 hora local en un
edificio de la universidad antes de
dirigirse a otro edificio donde también
se escucharon disparos tuvieron que
empezar a cerrarlo todo y mis amigos
atrincheraron porque no sabíamos que
estaba pasando según las autoridades el
sospechoso de 43 años fue encontrado
muerto en el lugar de los hechos pero
por el momento dicen ignorar porque
abrió fuego Estados Unidos está pagando
un alto precio por la proliferación de
armas y la facilidad con la que los
estadounidenses tienen acceso a ellas
uno de cada tres adultos posee al menos
un arma y casi uno de cada dos adultos
vive en un hogar con un arma Y es que
este tiroteo en Michigan se produjo un
día antes del quinto aniversario de la
masacre en la escuela marjoriedman
Douglas en parkland Florida que dejó 17
personas muertas se trata de uno de los
peores tiroteos escolares en la historia
de Estados Unidos Este martes Como cada
año se llevaron a cabo homenajes para
honrar a las víctimas en la ciudad de
Miramar también en Florida miembros de
la comunidad formaron un corazón gigante
con el número 17 en su interior que
simboliza la cifra de fallecidos
en otras noticias de Estados Unidos las
autoridades federales detuvieron a
cuatro personas señaladas de estar
presuntamente involucradas en el
magnicidio del presidente de Haití
benelmois en 2021 entre ellos se
encuentra un ciudadano de origen
venezolano propietario de City usecurity
la empresa acusada de reclutar a ex
soldados colombianos para asesinar a
moises y también el representante de la
compañía Un hombre de origen colombiano
ambos son acusados de conspirar para
llevar a cabo el crimen con ellos ya son
en total 11 personas bajo custodia
estadounidense por su supuesta
participación en el magnicidio
según la denuncia tres de los acusados
arrestados hoy operaban negocios aquí en
el sur de la Florida y esperaban obtener
beneficios inesperados de los contratos
de seguridad y construcción que
otorgarían quienes creían que asumirían
el poder en Haití tras la muerte del
presidente Moisés con el uso de términos
codificados como tornillos clavos y
herramientas para referirse a armas y
municiones
las comunicaciones entre los
conspiradores revelan un plan calculado
que pretendía alentar disturbios civiles
como una tapadera para la entrada de los
asesinos a la residencia del presidente
para llevar a cabo un golpe que resultó
en su muerte
y en Colombia poca afluencia tuvieron
las marchas convocadas por el gobierno
del presidente Gustavo Petro en apoyo a
las primeras de las grandes reformas que
contempla en su agenda se trata de la
Reforma a la salud que fue radicada en
el congreso este lunes y que le ha
generado críticas en el centro de Bogotá
no se logró reunir a la suficientes
personas para llenar la Plaza de Armas
del palacio presidencial desde un balcón
desde la casa de nariño sede del
gobierno el mandatario seguro que estos
proyectos buscan construir un bienestar
social para todos para este miércoles Se
esperan movilizaciones a nivel nacional
convocadas por la oposición
y chile sigue combatiendo uno de los
peores incendios forestales de su
historia sólo en 10 días se ha quemado
más territorio que en varios años de
temporadas de incendios se estima que al
menos
425.000 hectáreas perdidas las llamas
afectan especialmente a tres regiones
del Sur
ñuble La araucanía y biobío donde se
decretó el estado de catástrofe con la
muerte de un rescatista Este martes la
cifra de fallecidos aumentó a 25 hay más
de 2.700 lesionados y 1.250 casas
quemadas muchas en zonas Rurales de
difícil acceso visitamos a una de estas
personas que vieron como sus hogares
desaparecían por completo en solo apenas
unas horas
los incendios en el sur de chile
continúan Arrasando todo a su paso los
vecinos de la comuna de walkie una zona
rural y aislada en la región sureña del
bío bío no olvidarán jamás este verano
austral en el que se han visto acosados
por las llamas
Juan agricultor uno de Los afectados en
el área de Chamizal pudo salvar su casa
y también todos sus animales solo perdí
un galpón y madera pero su tía que vive
al lado no corrió con la misma suerte
a ver el fuego como veníamos tuve que
evacuar y algunos quedaron acá que
después yo subí Por acá de una parrilla
fui a dejar abajo a mi mamá al pueblo
que ayudar acá lejos de ella las llamas
también devoraron la casa de Marilyn que
nos muestra la arquitectura emocional de
las cenizas de su hogar
y detrás estaba la casita de mi hermana
ganar Sí con salida todo independiente
pero compartíamos esta parte que en la
cocina no estaba Cuando ocurrió el fuego
y le costó asimilar que la casa que
había heredado de sus padres ya no
estaba más esa noche necesito
tranquilizantes para dormir No yo amo
mucho este lugar y esto que nos pasó no
lo esperábamos nosotros Nunca pensamos
yo pensé el campo se nos puede quemar
pero la casa nunca pensé que se iba a
quemar esposo Jorge que presenció como
su casa ardía Sin poder salvarla tiene
ese momento grabado en su memoria un
pero era algo que habíamos construido
con esfuerzo con dedicación palo palo y
quedarse sin nada Así de la noche a la
mañana
la resiliencia chilena en una tierra
acostumbrada a levantarse frente a las
catástrofes se abre paso Marilyn Jorge
Nancy y Roberto comienzan a planear poco
a poco Cómo ponerse en pie de nuevo en
Argentina la crisis económica golpea los
bolsillos de los ciudadanos debido a la
fuerte alza inflacionaria que en 2022
llegó al 95% anual se espera que este
año las cifras supere los tres dígitos
un panorama difícil para el actual
mandatario de Cara a las elecciones
generales de octubre Andrés granadillo
con los detalles
una crisis galopante que obliga a los
médicos y profesores argentinos a vivir
al día sin posibilidades de un cambio a
la vista y la verdad trato de dividir el
día a día Busco precios recorro mercados
este
buscamos buscamos donde están más barata
la carne donde está más cara más barata
la verdura
uno va jugando con las promociones
online viste y así uno se va moviendo
Argentina Lleva años lidiando con una
elevada inflación 2022 cerró en un dato
del 95% anual y este año podría
acelerarse a pesar de las medidas del
gobierno de Alberto Fernández Voy
comprando semana por semana porque ya no
hago una compra grande y bueno y lo veo
y hay cosas que dejó de comprar digo no
esto es imposible que aumente así
no lo compro cambio los hábitos o compro
ofertas El Banco Central ha subido las
tasas de interés al
75%, lo que ha ocasionado que los
argentinos duden de la buena gestión del
presidente peronista del centro
izquierda de Cara a las elecciones
generales de octubre donde la oposición
conservadora va por delante en las
encuestas los argentinos están hartos de
la inflación y muchos culpan a la mala
gestión económica y a la impresión de
dinero por parte del gobierno en el 2001
te dejaban trabajar ahora con el tema de
importación
cerrado muchas partes no pueden trabajar
ni siquiera O sea a nosotros mismos nos
pasa también en nuestro rubro porque
entre impuestos pago de acá pago de allá
te ahogan y no te dejan trabajar en
Argentina el costo de los alimentos la
gasolina y los servicios supera con
creces el de los salarios por lo que es
cada vez más difícil subsistir en el
país suramericano hasta aquí este
informativo Gracias por acompañarnos
[Música]